hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares okay we got a fake book
which I can only assume goes in the
library for some reason or another I
don't know why I need a fake book but I
got one so let me go over here
I thought needs to be put anywhere cuz I
don't think so
why else would I have needed to put up a
fake book oh that was the whole gap okay
okay oh crap what is this what is this
malarkey what is this baloney why am i
down here oh I don't deserve this I
deserve so much better than this
this is where he was moving around this
is a little power drill massacre going
on here
this isn't even a different room that
still eight ten is all eight 1008 ten
sucks eight ten is a [ __ ] alright okay
so what awaits me down here in 810
probably nothing good
things seem oh crap crap exit key keeps
going we're gonna break it down right
away come on already enough of this
baloney come on yeah that's what I
thought
big Oh God don't check the only closet
oh he's so twitchy don't do it yeah
that's right don't do it bro don't do it
don't do it don't do it
I reveal he's gonna turn out badly for
me
like eventually this has got to stop
working right look is he's not gonna
leave
okay maybe none I didn't see him go out
the door you know like you like you know
like you know like you know like you
know like you know lucky lucky not like
you know no likey no no like you know no
Markey like you know no oh little piggy
no no please you no no no no no no no no
no no no oh God jeez Peugeot oh my god
that was so the power drill massacre
sound oh my god oh my god oh man oh god
oh man
okay okay I'm okay okay okay alright
okay moving on now oh that's the end of
that great okay just done that was all
there was soon okay whoa
okay hello mr. dream shrunk all right
then cool man this is not oh those not
fun oh man if it wasn't so fun why do I
get a big smile plastered on my face on
me Oh tell me who me and me why sad
music happening that was a good thing
the music was crescendoing to something
alright something not good oh not good
anyway I think we're okay think we're
doing just fine
Oh God musics just not good terms
undermine me that the case here okay
I still hear him breathing oh man's out
what the no was talking about I think
he's still here
damnit
Lumpkin bastard they are not my friend
they are not my friend I'm gonna be the
one death that those things actually
caused oh you always weird because the
model of that dude he wasn't even all
that like scary uses like super
unnerving not goddamn even that startled
me
not okay with this not okay with this uh
it's more than just jump scares okay
oh good has the mood finally changed or
are we just moving on to another
nightmare now another horrible
monstrosity that I don't want to deal
with like this puzzle room
damnit there we go moving on
Oh
actually all right
okay almost 850 once you get to 850 you
don't know if it's gonna have another
save point cuz I'm pretty sure they only
come every hundred but you never know
because 750 actually was a spot where it
had that I think the effectiveness of
the specimens is also somehow related to
the souls of the people that kill
somehow anyway I'm still alive and
strong but I feel like might be in most
cave of my journey lies ahead
I wonder what the antagonist will look
like I hope they're cute well maybe not
I don't know about you but the rest of
Spooky's friends ain't too cute given
some of the cuter ones turned a little
diabolical after a while damnit
oh [ __ ] you god damn you cute skeleton
bastard alright so I guess there was
nothing at 8:50 I gotta blast all the
way through it at 900 I guess I'm gonna
blast my bestest I'm gonna blast as
hearty as I can but I can't make any
promises
oh crap
there we go oh I am here I don't help me
nah I just gotta keep moving forward and
hope that nothing else horrible happen
stop it I don't want any of your bowl
actually I'll take plenty of your rest
of the monstrosity Zin this castle is
with you Jesus you're such a weirdo okay
so anyway okay I don't know even know
what it is about this game like it gets
me it gets me very good
it gets me very good cleanness in that
it's very good at what it does it's
surprisingly effective for how
minimalistic the styling of and I
probably talked about this board I
really remember the first time I played
it was a while ago but it's bizarre
because every time I come in here it's
definitely the sound that hits me first
oh hello bones the weird sounds hit me
first because the sound design in this
game is actually very good it's creepy
and you'll notice like the sound fear is
so much rise like it's not even
horror-themed like throughout the entire
game it's a bunch of different varying
themes that breathing a her and like
you'll do that little do that loose like
did I hear what I think I heard and it
does that very effectively so even
though it's cartoony and pretty and cute
and that's what the original draw this
game was that really caught people off
guard like even despite that it's almost
like it just looks like a juxtaposition
like that octopus was but I like it
juxtaposition the more you play the game
because the game stays cute the horror
just gets worse
know what I mean so I don't know how to
properly describe you but you guys know
what I'm talking about I think so anyway
I once tonight I just got to get through
this - 900 900 baby that's different
that's different that's different that
is different why is that different
I don't like it I don't like different
Oh [ __ ] you what is that don't give
seizures to my audience Wow oh god I
don't like that oh you're a growling oh
here grab the growling don't look good
was that the door opening by me boy but
it was all crap stop that stop that I
can't see
okay bad bad bad bad bad bad got against
nine hundred billion tonight hundred
gotta get it done hundred hmm okay
routed oh crap I'm pretty sure hunter
fancy other like see you think I don't
to set up and I wanna seven find out do
not want to stop
okay 96 come that's breathing
this is everything ready go go go go go
go okay
brink it ain't $99.99 and soothing okay
we're okay we're okay we're okay okay
you can do it we can help half a chance
what I just realized that I never had a
mentor figure trial or leaving home
scene that means the story isn't
following the archetypes to make me a
traditional hero which means I can be
killed off well he was at least it was
nice for a little while at least
okay good job rationalizing it okay oh
yeah so that was rooms 800 to 900 so I'm
going to probably get to the end of this
in the next episode so stay tuned for
that I still do
so thank you everybody so much for
watching the game z-score scare games
that I've done and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye bye and a
whole dinner to do we are gonna be out
for a challenge
hello what was that
what